SPEAKER: You can use the
Alerting feature in Google
Cloud Monitoring to be notified
when issues or failures occur
within your application.
To create your first
alerting policy,
look for the Create Alerting
Policy button on your dashboard
or via the Alerting menu
at the top of the screen.
When you create
your first policy,
you'll begin by
giving it a name.
In this case, I'll
call it Test Policy.
You may want to choose
a more descriptive name
given that this is included in
any notifications about alerts.
Next, you select the
type of condition
under which the policy will
trigger a notification.
In this case, we'll use a
metric threshold condition,
which is to describe
a case where
I want to be alerted
when a metric crosses
a threshold for
a period of time.
I'm an App Engine user.
And in this case, I want
to be alerted related
to an App Engine module.
So I'll select the App
Engine Module resource type.
And I'm concerned
with a single module.
So I'll say Single.
And then I'll choose the
module for the policy.
In this case, it's
the Comments module.
I click Next.
Then I select the metric
that I want to evaluate.
In this case, I could've
chosen total responses
or 500 responses.
But I'm primarily
concerned right now
with response latencies,
95th percentile.
I select that metric.
And I see a preview
of the metric
down the bottom of the screen,
which shows that metric's
performance over the last hour.
In this case, I
want to be alerted
if the 95th percentile
response latency
is above 900 milliseconds.
Again, I see a preview of
that threshold on the chart.
And I'll choose to
be alerted if it
stays above that level
for five minutes.
And that's it.
I'll save my condition.
Next, I should choose
how I want to be notified
when the alert is triggered.
I can be notified via email,
SMS, or popular services,
such as PagerDuty, HipChat,
Campfire, or Slack.
In this case,
we'll choose email.
And I simply enter
the email address.
And then save the alert.
Now I'll be notified if
my 95th percentile latency
for my Comments module exceeds
the threshold for five minutes.